if you're ashamed of who you are and
you're feeling like
no one else is gonna get me it's not
true
[Music]
i am a fully out lesbian woman
and i was raised in the jehovah's
witness household i grew up
roman catholic in houston texas
yes the south and land of beyonce i grew
up in a
religious household it was very
strict and unloving i grew up in an
orthodox jewish community
i grew up in a catholic household i got
baptized when i was a senior in high
school
and then i ended up going to a really
conservative christian college
i grew up in a very catholic religious
household we're also part of the
charismatic renewal group so we were
even deeper into the church
i realized really quickly how the church
viewed queerness and
it was not positive just because this is
my catholic experience
does not mean that every catholic person
or every catholic experience was like
this but
for me in my small town the way
that catholicism was expressed was very
aggressively
i hear a lot of sermons talking about
the lifestyle
that i am living is deeming me to hell
so i kept it secret
for so long one chaplain particular
the pastor is up there saying that he
took a trip with his family to puerto
rico
and that he saw men holding hands
together and was wondering
why did i pay all this money to have to
see something like that the atrocity the
the sin and i remember sitting there
feeling so
crappy because essentially he was
talking about me there were lots of
strict rules and laws that we had to
stick to
it made it very very hard to be able to
express myself
most of the time i just felt like i was
a walking contradiction i didn't
identify with the person that i was
portraying
to the outside world i actually really
enjoyed
singing in mass but then when it came
down to
being gay it wasn't
wasn't something i felt accepted with
one of my
most embarrassing and hurtful times was
when uh as the choir director honor of
the tenors
are saying in a nice beautiful terrible
tenor voice
reggie is a
nobody nobody
stood up and said a word for me that
was absolutely devastating i was taught
that being gay was
playing all wrong you know you were
going to hell i remember before i came
out it felt like i had already lost
everybody in my life growing up queer
and black
i really was just trying to survive
so much of me was so scared that my
parents
that my community that my friends
would no longer support me for the
longest time i thought i was the only
one there was an example of someone like
me when i was growing
up that told me it was okay to be who i
was
realizing that i was part of the lgbt
community was
very empowering on one hand but on the
other hand it was also very scary
every single week after i came out that
i went to church i would just pray that
the news hadn't spread
i felt dirty i didn't feel like i could
be myself
i felt ashamed of who i was at first you
know i felt very ashamed i tried to pray
it away
i left the church when i was 16 years
old because i told my mother
i don't want to come here anymore i
heard a lot of things about
don't do this don't do that but i did
not hear very much about
love and when i read the bible i was
seeing a lot of things about love
and then i had a lot of conversations
with myself and with god
i just came to the conclusion that it
was okay to be
who i was when i came out i lost
most of my friends and then i moved
across the country and made
so many amazing friends that loved me
not despite who i was but because of who
i was
once i went away out of state for
college i kind of allowed myself to
truly explore who i was
in new york city i could be 100 reginald
anywhere i am and if i can't be 100
regularly anywhere i am
i don't go there it was a very long
journey to come to where i am with my
parents now
but i think it's a great place
is there still room to grow yes but i
think that where we're at
is a place that i never thought we would
be even three years ago
my relationship with my mother has grown
stronger i didn't come out to my mother
until actually i was
19 years old she smiled and said
reginald
i kind of thought so but i never taught
you who to love
i just taught you to love and no matter
who you are
or what you do you'll always be my son
and i will always love you i've learned
to love myself because i deserve to
i deserve love i feel safer even in a
world that is still not
safe for me i still feel safer because i
know
that i'm living the life that i want to
live i think that i'm
finally at a place where i am a hundred
percent confident
in my sexuality and no part of me feels
ashamed
or hidden or like a problem
anymore and if you are a person of faith
who does love and accept all queer
identities and all people in general
let that be known if you are an lgbtq
youth they're living in an intolerant
environment i know that you probably
can't get away but know this
you are completely loved and you are
completely lovable
just because you are enough
if you are being made to feel that your
sexuality
is inherently wrong that is a reflection
of
them and not you people are going to
make you feel authorized
section off like a sinner and you know
what that's not your problem
that is not your problem your one job in
this life is to be authentic
period and if they don't love you
there's a whole community of queer
people
who will embrace you and love you as
their own you are not alone
you are not alone i mean i'm sitting
right here i'm d
do you see my queer body i'm literally
right here you are not a sinner
you are worthy of love there is a world
out there that wants to celebrate you
you just gotta find it i think god made
me exactly the way i'm supposed to be
and that's the end of it and i'm a proud
and out lesbian woman
god it is like really great to say that
today
i can say i am a proud queer man
who loves to genderbend and
explore his sexuality
in a way that i truly never thought that
i would
my name is reginald thomas brown
my pronouns are they in them i
am a queer gender non-conforming black
revolutionary who is loving my life
like it's gold
[Music]
you